today on visualpolitik we are going to
present the most 2021 story of the year
it goes like this thousands of iraqi
asylum seekers on the border shared by
poland and belarus what's so special
about that take a look at this map
iraq is here belarus is here and poland
is here you're thinking well i'm
thinking aren't you what are iraqis
doing crossing the border between
belarus and poland well that's what
we're going to tell you in this video
[Music]
what we have is this on the belarussian
side up to 7 000 iraqis syrians iranians
afghans and lebanese they're on the
border and what they want is to enter
the european union which way through the
three eu countries that have the immense
good fortune of being belarus's
neighbors we are talking about poland
lithuania and latvia as you can imagine
none of them are happy to suddenly see
all of these people on their border and
to top it all off it's not like anyone's
being welcomed with open arms check this
out
[Music]
violence erupts on poland belarus border
as polish guards fire water cannon on
migrants throwing rocks exactly there's
a hail of stones on one side water
cannons and tear gas on the other
migrants trying to break down border
posts poland reinforcing the border
lithuania starting to build a wall nato
considering intervening and all of this
happened in less than a month
the almost 7 500 miles or 1200
kilometers of border between belarus and
the european union have seen so much
action that even the latest james bond
film would pale in comparison and you'll
probably see let's see grant you're
painting it as a gargantuan crisis but
seven thousand people between three
countries it's not that big a deal is it
after all in 2015 the eu received more
than a million asylum seekers and
continues to do so well tell that to the
prime minister of poland ladies and
gentlemen
i turn to you because europe
our common home is threatened as you can
see for poland what is happening on its
border is a full-blown declaration of
war and if mr of morowitzky was saying
two months ago that the eu is
blackmailing him there he is appealing
to brussels and to common values
now in any case poland would not be the
only victim in this story because at the
time of making this video at least 13
migrants have lost their lives remember
that we are also talking about families
we're talking about children even
newborns above all we're talking about
winter
boy 14 dies from cold on belarus border
as migrants weaponized in escalating
crisis and the questions you might be
pondering are one used as weapons by
whom who is the bad guy in the story the
evil mastermind behind it all too what
on earth are the iraqis doing crossing
the border between poland and belarus
three and where are they now what was
the outcome of all this was it one of
those stories we won't even remember
tomorrow or should we really be worried
today we're gonna answer all of these
questions but first let's take a little
trip down history road
the man who wanted to be a super villain
i know i know what some of you are
thinking surely russia must be involved
here because of course we are talking
about belarus russia a country that
doesn't typically pull the strings of
international politics on its own and
indeed there are people who say that
everything that's happening now on the
belarusian border is part of putin's
grand plan to destabilize europe in
order to make russia great again and
dominate the world but the truth is that
at least technically it doesn't make
much sense that this belarusian crisis
is being orchestrated from moscow what's
more it wouldn't be the first time that
belarus has imposed itself on the
interests of its russian big brother in
this story it looks like mr lukashenko
is the sole author
[Music]
and who is lukashenko for those of you
who are new to visualpolitik welcome and
haven't yet seen all the videos we've
made about belarus i'm going to give you
a slight spoiler belarus is a
dictatorship what's more it is the last
great dictatorship in europe and on top
of that it doesn't try to disguise it at
all in fact it pretty much does the
opposite if a dictator pride day is ever
invented lukashenko would be the queen
of the parade check this nonsense so
it's better to be a dictator than gay
declares belarus president yes that's
right mr alexander lukashenko some kids
want to be astronauts or youtubers he
wanted to be a dictator
you heard about let me make even clearer
alexander lukashenko is a man who wanted
to be a super villain and as far as that
plan goes he hasn't done too badly he
has become the dictator of a country of
nine million inhabitants
[Music]
he came to power 27 years ago and he's
enjoyed it so much that he's decided to
stay if possible forever and of course
as there is a growing part of the
population that is not happy to live
under a dictatorship the belarusian
regime has been gradually tightening its
fist in recent years firstly by banning
protests with fines arrests police
charges and various repressions secondly
by restricting freedom of the press as
of today there are several media outlets
that have either had to be shut down or
are inaccessible from belarus we are
talking about a full-blown offensive
belarus journalists jailed for two years
for live streaming protest
a new site read by more than 40 of
belarusian internet users has been
blocked and its editors questioned after
their offices and houses were raided by
authorities given all this it should
come as no surprise that belarus is the
country with the least press freedom in
all of europe yes it's even worse than
turkey and you can probably imagine how
politics works in this country
[Music]
the last presidential elections were
held in august last year at first things
looked surprisingly good lucashenko was
obviously the main candidate but there
was also several opposition names on the
provisional ballot that had popular
support and there were even analysts who
said look maybe it's time for a
transition a new president and maybe
just maybe even a little bit of
democracy if you've been following
visualpolitik for a while you already
know what happened because we dedicated
an entire video to it at the time by the
way this is a great moment where we
should remind you to subscribe to this
channel and take a look at our patreon
page but that's enough of that let's get
back to today's story
[Music]
in case you don't remember what happened
in the latest belarusian elections
here's a summary in three news items
belarus bans two opposition candidates
from running in elections
belarus opposition figures detained
before presidential vote
belarus election opposition leader
tikanovskaya left for sake of her
children as you can imagine when
election day came neither protests nor
international pressure were enough to
guarantee even a minimum level of
transparency and with that lukashenko
began his sixth term in office more
dictatorial than ever to make it clear
there are up to 800 political prisoners
in belarusian jails today and no one is
safe because lukachenko's regime has
very long arms
just check out one of the most surreal
news stories of this year
ryanair flight carrying an opposition
journalist is forced to land in belarus
that's right under the guise of a fake
bomb threat belarus hijacked a ryan
airplane that was flying from greece to
lithuania all to bring down an
opposition journalist and take him to
prison that's right we're all thinking
the same thing orion airplane so you
know next time you fly on a low-cost
airling maybe don't complain if your
seat isn't comfortable or if they don't
let you take your suitcase on board just
be thankful that belarus hasn't hijacked
your entire flight come on if lucashenko
doesn't deserve a supervillain of the
year award for that alone i don't know
what else to tell you guys or hang on
yes what about this ultimate evil plan
the strategy nominated for 2021
dictatorial screwballs awards we're
gonna look at that
now
more maxwell smart than smart
before i talk about this idea of the
century i have to tell you one thing
obviously lukashenko's trickery does not
only have an impact on belarus remember
that ryanair flight until may of this
year no one thought that a country
however dictatorial could hijack a
commercial airliner flying over its
airspace in this way of course the
european union and others haven't stood
idly by what they are doing is imposing
sanctions and other such measures we are
talking for example about an embargo on
arms and other goods that could be used
for repression but above all we are
talking about sanctions with a name and
a surname against 166 representatives of
the regime their assets are frozen and
they cannot travel to or through the eu
obviously alexander lukashenko himself
is one of those sanctioned and the eu
does not recognize his government
[Music]
well i think you can imagine what the
dynamic is belarus takes one more step
towards a perfect dictatorship the eu
responds with a sanction package belarus
represses journalists another sanctions
package falsifying elections another
hijack a plane more sanctions and here
we have mr lucashenko doing whatever he
wants for decades even if his people
have to suffer the consequences if you
think being a dictator is easy you are
wrong but then again maybe if the eu is
your neighbor you're not
on the one hand he wants to have the
last word because he needs to project a
strong image both to the population that
still supports him and to the outside
world but on the other hand tell me what
can belarus do to fight against the eu
and that's when this man and his
eagerness to be an evil genius said okay
how can i attack the eu and get some
revenge for these trade sanctions and if
possible force them to sit down at the
table with me and recognize me as
president can i
attack them with my army no can i wager
a trade war like putin once did with
natural gas net can i send terrorists
there no well we're getting close to the
climax of this thought process i don't
know whether lukashenko has seen the
queen's gamba and thinks he's a
strategist or whether he just dreamed it
all up but what you're about to see has
happened in real life check this out
belarus dictator threatens to flood eu
with drugs and migrants come on doesn't
that sound like a super villain movie
idea besides it may seem surprising but
when lukashenko wants something nothing
is impossible
[Music]
let's recap the moves step one organize
a migration crisis the first thing you
need are migrants themselves right and
if you don't have them at hand you have
to bring them to you how by organizing
whole publicity campaign in countries
where people have many reasons to want
to leave iraq syria lebanon afghanistan
and other hot spots around the world to
convince them promises like this should
probably do it
common misinformation spread in the past
included every refugee receives a
welcome payment of 2 000 euros a welcome
payment in germany a guaranteed job in
the eu these are just some of the
promises behind this migration crisis
[Music]
so now we're on step two let's get down
to the logistics how do we bring all
these people to the eu's doorstep very
easily by issuing belarusian tourist
visas like there's no tomorrow once we
have them we put these tourists on irish
plains operated by belarusian airline
when they arrive in belarus we bring
them to the border and tell them where
they need to go to cross the border into
poland and then to get to germany and
voila the magic trick of pulling a
migration crisis out of the bag is done
and now you're going to ask me do we
have any certainty that belarus is
helping the migrants get to the border
well let's see
come on repeat what mr lukashenko said
to disassemble is for the week now that
you know what the master plan consists
of tell me what could go wrong well
we're going to look at that now
[Music]
the new hybrid war
sure maybe lukashenko was convinced that
brussels would insist on accepting and
distributing migrants and asylum seekers
poland was opposite as it did in 2016
and that with this the eu's eastern and
western blocks would enter into a civil
war to the death but the truth is that
the eu has shown itself to be rather
more cohesive than lukashenko expected
possibly for the first time ever the
european commission has earmarked 792
thousand dollars for the humanitarian
aid and the red cross is operating in
the area poland and lithuania are
reinforcing their borders there is a lot
of room for improvement but at least for
the moment the situation is
de-escalating and this is because the
first thing the eu did was to turn off
the migration tap firstly they talked to
the countries of origin and transit
pressuring them for example with the
possibility of taking away development
aid secondly they also put pressure on
airlines by threatening them with
sanctions as a result transit countries
such as uzbekistan turkey or the united
arab emirates began to restrict flights
to belarus in addition the iraqi
government has allocated planes to start
bringing its own people back
hundreds of migrants arrived back in
iraq on flight from belarus and you may
see so that's it isn't it this is a very
specific story that happened in belarus
and it has no repercussions for the rest
of the world well surprising as it may
seem this is not the first time that
migrants and asylum seekers have been
used as a political weapon
we saw this with turkey in 2015 and more
recently with morocco turkey was in the
path of one of the main migration routes
after the syrian war and that is
precisely why it was able to impose its
conditions on the 2016 migration
agreement basically and kara received
european funds in exchange for
controlling the access of migrants and
asylum seekers to the eu today the
country remains a key gatekeeper so
whether it likes it or not brussels has
to rely on erdogan and this year in
spain we saw migration crisis organized
by morocco another country that acts as
a migration filter for europe after a
swahili leader was hospitalized in the
northern spanish city of lagrange what
coincidence by the way thousands of
migrants suddenly started arriving in
theota as you can see migrants and
asylum seekers are indeed used to lobby
in international politics and okay
belarus is also a country that borders
the eu but unlike turkey and morocco
belarus is not in the middle of a
migration flow
[Music]
if there is one thing the polish prime
minister and ursula van der leyden agree
on is that lukashenko is trying to
orchestrate a hybrid war with completely
artificial migration crises so the
question is was it worth it well no okay
lucashengo has managed to get everyone's
attention he's even spoken twice with
angle america but that's where his
advantages end besides let's see what he
does when the migrants who don't make it
to poland but don't return to iraq
either if they stay in minsk lukashenko
will most likely flood himself with all
those asylum seekers now of course this
is not a bad thing for belarus but it
could lead to political problems
remember that unlike europe belarus does
not have sufficient resources to
integrate all those migrants nor does it
have a labor market that can absorb them
we'll be keeping an eye on how events
unfold in the coming months but
everything indicates that lukashenko
wanted to be a supervillain from a bond
movie and he's instead become kind of a
doctor evil but now the question is over
to you what do you think of lukashenko's
plan do you know of any other cases
where migrants are used as weapons and
how would you act in this case if you
were in brussels you can leave your
answers in the comments below as always
don't forget that here on visualpolitik
we release new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel and hit the
little bell down there so you don't miss
any of our updates if you like this
video like it so we can find out and
feel all chuffed with ourselves take
care and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you